[intro music]
Good morning, Hank!
John: Perfect! You were supposed
to say "it's Tuesday," though.
[crowd laughs]
John: So, let's try it again, but this time
say "it's Tuesday." Ready? One, two three:
Crowd: It's Tuesday!
I'm in the airport in New York City.
Hank, I'm at the airport in Washington, D.C.
So, for some reason that I don't understand, Penguin got me the couple's Valentine's special here at my
hotel in Washington, D.C.
So last night I was treated to a dinner where I got two entrées, two appetizers, and two desserts.
Sorry, Weight Watchers.
And now I'm in the airport in Chicago.
I know what you're wondering, Hank. You're wondering, "John, how are you getting from airport to airport?
Are you using a hovercraft?
Are you using Movie Magic?"
No, I'm using airplanes.
And that's unfortunate, because you know what? Airplanes hate snow.
Most of the people here at the moment are cameramen asking people what it's like that all the flights are being cancelled.
So I thought I would recreate one of those interviews.
So, how do you feel about all these delays?
Um.... they suck.
Could you actually, could you-could you-put my question back into your answer?
Um... all these delays... of my flight... suck.
Hank, I've spent 12 of the last 40 hours inside of airports, and you may be wondering how I pass the time when I'm here.
And the answer is simple: I've been hard at work on my 2007 celebrity death pool lineup.
A celebrity death pool is where you pick 24 people who you think will die in the next year.
It's really, you know, it's like... it's like good, clean fun. It's a way that I can give back.
You know?
The key to playing the game and still being able to live with yourself is to pick people that you're kind of rooting for.
Or at least that you're OK with the idea.
I mean, obviously you never want anyone to die, but if people have to, and, from what I understand, they do,
they might as well be members of al-Qa'ida.
So I'd like to say a preemptive goodbye to all those I hope we will be missing come January 1st, 2008.
[song plays] This song is for the rats who hurled themselves into the ocean
[song cont's] when they saw that the explosives in the cargo hold were just about to blow
[song cont's] This song is for the soil that's toxic clear down to the bedrock
[song cont's] where no thing of consequence can grow, drop your seeds there, let them go
[song cont's] let them all go!
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.